the united nations says more than 660
000 people have fled ukraine since the
invasion began just a week ago the
majority of the people have headed for
poland the u.n fears that number could
rise as high as
4 million in just the next few weeks
now shelters have been set up along the
border
with ukraine
our next report comes from
shaymin shul where polish people
are giving some of the refugees a warm
welcome
another train arrives at prejemisha
station in poland
on board refugees who are fleeing from
the neighboring war zone in ukraine
most arriving here are women
children and the elderly
at the moment ukrainian men aged between
18 and 60 who are fit for military
service are not allowed to leave ukraine
it is hard to leave very hard especially
for little children but somehow we did
it and we're here now
i am glad for the children but i am very
worried about the family members who
decided to stay in ukraine
we are so grateful to the polish people
who are helping ukraine putin is a sick
man something is wrong with him
if he were smart he wouldn't have begun
the war in the first place we're living
in the 21st century
volunteers give the refugees food and
everyday items they might find useful
in the main hall cots have been laid out
so the ukrainians can rest
outside the station volunteers offer the
newcomers a free ride to the next city
they take them to katowice krakow or
even berlin
i can give three people a ride for
example a woman and two children i'm
willing and able to help
poland is well prepared for this stream
of people
for weeks they've been following
government orders to set up aid centers
like this one called ukrainian house to
offer help including temporary
accommodation
[Music]
but these are chaotic times
and not everyone fleeing ukraine has
found poland quite so welcoming
including foreign students
the ukrainians who are
who are let
some have also complained of poor
treatment at the hands of the border
guards
all the black people arabic people
especially they what i saw they beat
them they told they are gone to them at
night it was snowing like just people
wanted to walk they stop us like a three
hour they didn't let us walk like and
people get like aggressive
poland says it's admitted around 350 000
people from more than 120 countries
with war raging just a few kilometers
away sympathy for the refugees is mixed
with a fear of what might come next
[Music]
my next guest is chris meltzer he's a
senior spokesperson with the un refugee
agency
unhcr he joins me tonight
near the polish border with
you craig chris it's good to have you on
the program
has europe just let's just talk about
this
in its largest terms has europe seen
anything like this
since
1945
clear and short answer no there were a
big refugee crisis you remember in the
90s
when the balkan wars drove so many
people out of former yugoslavia there
were in 1956 when the russian invasion
to hungary
went to a refugee crisis that so many
people
fled for example to austria and other
european countries but um 660 000 people
as you have mentioned within less than
five days this is really unprecedented
just yesterday um
100 000 people came to po to poland
alone with 24 hours this is really
without example
and are these refugees are they getting
the support that they need
more or less yes i mean you need always
more support but
the the polish government is well
prepared here
facilities for the refugees uh makeshift
facilities and schools in gymnasiums and
so on the people can rest there and can
probably think what the next step could
be and the solidarity of the people here
of ordinary people who doing
extraordinary things it's it's just
amazing that um
you saw that in the in in
in the
in the video of your of your colleagues
it's really fantastic how the people
here in poland are supporting the
refugees
and we we have had reports that
non-ukrainian
citizens trying to flee the country have
not been allowed to leave particularly
people from
africa and asia are you hearing those
reports
uh
not in that way we have heard that
that they had problems to enter poland
that um the polish authorities
took them out for for for clear um
uh clearing when there were problems
with the papers and so on and we are
very concerned about these cases but we
have not heard that really people were
sent back to ukraine that would be a
breach of the 1951 refugee convention
and
a very serious problem
the countries bordering ukraine they're
very welcoming to
these refugees i mean this is a very
different story when you compare it to
the refugee crisis back in 2015 isn't it
well at least what the polls would say
now it's it's our direct neighbor and um
there's there's a war uh but with um the
um the position of the government and
also it's indeed also very different uh
what changed their mind well you should
ask them
yeah i mean
it is an interesting aspect of the story
chris we appreciate you taking the time
to put this in context for us chris
meltzer with the
unhcr chris thank you
thank you very much